mais auparavant le tour de l'actualité
de ce mercredi avec d'abord la situation
en nouvelle-calédonie qui nous a permis
de suivre un débat fort intéressant à
l'assemblée nationale ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas
un débat qui s'inscrivait dans une
séance de questions d'actualité c'est à
dire la procédure qui permet aux députés
d'interpeller les ministres qui leur
répondent immédiatement avec un face à
face au sommet puisque l'ancien
président giscard d'estaing intervenait
pour la première fois depuis son retour
au palais bourbon
c'est le premier ministre qui lui a
répondu monsieur fabius qui a notamment
indiqué qu'un débat sur la nouvelle
calédonie aurait lieu dans les quinze
jours à venir ecoutez-le échanges entre
l'ancien président de la république et
l'actuel premier ministre
la question se pose est de savoir
pourquoi être revenu sur l'application
de ce statut
quand vous avez évolué plus avec la
beauté et vous êtes revenu à la fois
dans la lettre et dans l'esprit
d'abord pendant son application vous
êtes véranda sécurité des libertés
publiques
monsieur bré min ma proposition à la
suivante puisque up pour vous pour votre
gouvernement l'autodétermination par est
appelé en écho d'indépendance permettait
aux néo calédonien de pouvoir exercer
librement leur choix et que nous
puissions préparer nous qui le
souhaitons avec peu
une autre formule un autre stature une
départementalisation progressive et
façon en effet les privilèges mais en
même temps assurant l'égalité
progressive des changes de toutes les
communautés
la communauté kanak les autres et la
communauté des français vivent sur place
et mettez
ouah au moment de l'autodétermination le
choix entre ces deux options
qu'est ce que le gouvernement souhaite
dans cette affaire éviter les
affrontements
trouver une solution qui respecte les
droits légitimes de chaque communauté et
je voudrais si vous le voulez bien
parmi les nombreux commentaires que ce
difficile dossier a fait jaillir vous en
citer un qui m'a plus particulièrement
touchées la difficulté du problème ne
date pas de mai 1981 et donc tous les
gouvernements depuis ces deux dernières
décennies ont une part de responsabilité
d'autre part parce que rien ne doit être
fait ou dit qui puisse rendre le climat
plus tendu
ce texte et de monsieur c'est asie je
constate monsieur le président giscard
d'estaing aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas
pas encore être d'accord avec le
gouvernement de la france
je souhaite que vous soyez au moins
d'accord avec monsieur spatiale graves
écarts de langage ou traduction au
vitriol de l'exaspération que nourrit
dans les milieux politiques la situation
en nouvelle calédonie un vif et grave
incident a opposé cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale au cours des
questions au gouvernement
un député rpr didier julia qui est le
délégué national du mouvement aux dom
tom et le président de l'assemblée louis
mermaz après une suspension de séance le
premier ministre laurent fabius a dit
son indignation
jean-louis le scène si vous arriviez
contre la constitution contre la
démocratie a donné le pouvoir à une
petite minorité appuyée sur des bandes
armées
vous aurez découvert le national
socialisme et cela nous ne l'accepterons
pas
ce n'est pas possible de laisser traîner
des mots aussi sale ce n'est pas
possible
retirer ses expressions je regrette on a
pas le droit que déshonoré les gens même
avec des si je vous demande de retirer
ces mots monsieur le président c'est
julien on n'a pas le droit de déshonorer
la france même avec des accents nouvelle
calédonie et chez julien vous me faites
vraiment pitié
je m'excuse la séance est suspendue une
heure plus tard le bureau de l'assemblée
n'ayant pas prononcé de sanction le
président stigmatise sans plus
et d'exprimer ici mes chers collègues
une très profonde réprobation
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
utiliser le mode à part taille et le
monde nazisme pour qualifier l'attitude
de la majorité et du gouvernement est
indigne est indigne
je permettrai de vous dire monsieur
seguin s'agissant du nazisme et de ses
conséquences sur la vie des hommes que
dans la famille moi je sais ce que ça
veut dire
[Applaudissements]
trois gendarmes massacrés à l'armé
blanche en nouvelle calédonie 27 autres
séquestrés quelque part dans la brousse
sur l'île d'ouvéa c'est le bilan de
l'opération commando
mené très tôt ce matin par les
indépendantistes kanaks difficile de
faire le point car il est actuellement 5
heures du matin à nouméa en nouvelle
calédonie seule certitude cette affaire
ravive les passions à la veille des
élections
dimanche les néo calédoniens sont
appelés aux urnes à la fois pour
l'élection présidentielle et pour les
élections régionales
le film des événements avec notre envoyé
spécial dominique tierces postés sur le
toit de l'aéroport d'ouvéa
les gendarmes ont pris position dont 100
hommes ont été envoyés en renfort de
nouméa trois morts trois gendarmes
abattus à l'armé blanche des machettes
des sabres la nouvelle a ébranlé le
territoire ils se sont fait surprendre
tôt ce matin dans le cantonnement de
fayaoué ils ont été désarmés et c'est
sans doute à cet instant que les coups
de feu ont claqué à rotation les
hélicoptères puma chargés d'hommes se
sont rendus sur les lieux au moment où
l'on apprenait que les assaillants
avaient pris en otage et on est avec eux
26 gendarmes sur toute l'île des
barrages ont été mis en place et pour
dick cook et oui le sénateur rpr
cette opération commando est un acte de
terrorisme
je crois qu'il est important
que tous les français condamnent
ardemment le terrorisme qui chauffe en
nouvelle calédonie à travers le film
caisse car ce ne sont pas des actions
d'hommes libres
ce soit des actions de chauffage et côté
indépendantiste une seule affirmation
c'était prévisible dans ma tribu à moi
il ya déjà beaucoup de jeunes qui disent
même pas de vue que mourir c'est vivre
et il faut absolument qu'on installe le
dialogue de monsieur pons a une grande
responsabilité dans tout ce qu'il a
voulu dire que les kanaks nous
n'existons pas qu'on ne sont pas le
peuple indigène
on ne dit pas ça un des peuples les
couilles comme nous vous ne sont pas
liés à la terre
ça va continuer vous êtes inquiet pour
qui pourrait se passer dans les jours
qui viennent
mais nous tous nous tous un moment
penser qu'on va crever
[Musique]
sur l'aéroport de magenta à nouméa
un homme lutte entre la vie et la mort
il vient d'être rapatriés de l'île où se
sont produits les affrontements
c'est le gendarme le plus grièvement
blessé il a trois balles dans la tête
avec lui trois mélanésiens eux aussi
atteint par balle à l'abdomen et aux
jambes
il faisait partie du commando le
sinistre ballet des avions qui ramenait
les familles des gendarmes vivante a
ouvert s'est poursuivie tard dans
l'après midi
nous sommes tenus à distance derrière
les vitres de ses camionnettes la
dépouille d'un des gendarmes tués
toutes les opérations de recherches ont
cessé dès la tombée de la nuit
elles reprendront demain matin à l'aube
à à nouméa à l'état major de la
gendarmerie
on pense que les 26 personnes prises en
otage ont été répartis par groupes dans
toute l'île à 48 heures du scrutin
régional et présidentielle les autorités
locales sont selon leur propre
expression très préoccupé là messieurs
bonsoir trois gendarmes ont été abattus
ce matin ouvéa et 27 autres sont à
l'heure actuelle détenus en otages par
des indépendantistes dans le nord de
l'île à proximité de la tribu d'hugo
salle des renforts vente immédiatement
été dépêchées sur place et une opération
est actuellement en cours pour récupérer
les otages et pour arrêter les auteurs
de cette agression
dès que la nouvelle a été connue une de
nos équipes s'est immédiatement rendu et
ouvert le reportage de benoît saudeau
même si le trafic commercial n'a jamais
été interrompues l'aéroport de los
présentait aujourd'hui son visage des
mauvais jours déclarée zone militaire
sous haute surveillance l'aérodrome et
ses bâtiments étaient entièrement
occupée par les forces de l'ordre qui
toute la journée ont reçu des renforts
ce que nous avons vu depuis ce matin ici
à ouvéa
c'est un va-et-vient de puma et deux
transall l'avion militaire
quelques camions militaires un
dispositif radio visiblement sophistiqué
puisque toutes les lignes téléphoniques
ont été coupées avec la grande terre de
nombreux gendarmes en armes dont
certains vous le voyez peut-être sont
postés actuellement sur les toits de
l'aéroport d'autres tapis le long de la
piste
à 13h47 après-midi un puma en provenance
de fayaoué à quatre kilomètres d'ici à
apporter des dépouilles que nous doute
que nous nous disent elles de trois
gendarmes
mais ce transport nous ne pouvons pas
vous les montrer ce soir car les cinq
journalistes qui ont fait le déplacement
de nouméa ce matin ont été littéralement
enfermé dans un hangar tout près de la
piste impossible naturellement dans ces
conditions de filmer quoi que ce soit et
de rapporter des images celles ci sont
donc prises à la sauvette c'est un puma
comme celui ci qui tout à l'heure à
évacuer les deux gendarmes et le mobile
qui auraient été abattus à l'armé
blanche au cours de l' attaque de la
brigade de fayaoué ce matin vers 8
heures ici on ne dispose que
d'informations partielles
on croit savoir que trois camions des
brigades et des armes auraient été
subtilisés
vous savez on sait aussi que l'épousé
d'un des gendarmes se serait réfugiée au
presbytère et que les enfants des écoles
auraient été ramenés chez eux par mesure
de sécurité
on sait enfin que dans le nord 27
gendarmes ont été prises en otages à
gossanah face aux centrales les lignes
téléphoniques ont été coupées on les
répare et tout à l'heure je pense à tout
ça est plus loin sur la route face à la
gendarmerie un nouveau barrage interdit
tout passage c'est là que ce matin la
brigade aurait été prise d'assaut et que
le drame se serait produit ouvéa
s'endort ce soir sous haute surveillance
bonsoir les suite des incidents
meurtriers de nouvelle calédonie et de
la prise en otage hier de 26 gendarmes à
l'issue d'un conseil restreint réuni par
le premier ministre à matignon le
ministre des dom-tom monsieur bernard
pons a immédiatement quitté paris en
début d'après-midi pour la nouvelle
calédonie où le fln kassa fait connaître
les conditions qu'il posait à la
libération des otages
parmi elles l'annulation des élections
territoriales dont les opérations
couplée avec celle de l'élection
présidentielle doivent commencer
incessamment puisque le jour et déjà
levé là bas la situation est très tendue
marie-odile pagnol d'importants renforts
de gendarmerie sont arrivés aujourd'hui
en nouvelle calédonie pour maintenir
l'ordre
au lendemain de l'attaqué meurtrière
d'ouvéa malgré cela de nombreux
incidents ont eu lieu sur la coupe est à
canala des coups de feu tiré sur une
voiture ont blessé trois européens
leurs jours ne sont pas en danger
heineken les forces de l'ordre ont eu
recours aux gaz lacrymogènes pour
disperser des manifestants
indépendantistes qui ont riposté par des
jets de pierres
dans l'île d'ouvéa plus de 300 hommes
patrouillent toujours afin de localiser
les 27 gendarmes otages et leurs
ravisseurs
le fln k s a fait connaître les
conditions de leur libération
annulation des élections régionales qui
doivent débuter dans quelques heures
retrait des forces de l'ordre d'ouvéa et
nomination d'un médiateur
léopold ii g rodier l'un des dirigeants
indépendantistes a ajouté que si ces
conditions n'étaient pas respectées
le fln caisse se mobiliseraient pendant
les trois prochains mois pour forcer le
futur président de la république quel
qu'il soit à négocier voilà pour le
territoire métropolitain en nouvelle
calédonie c'est la nuit maintenant les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
sont connus là-bas mais tenus secrets
jusqu'à 20h bien entendu en revanche
ceux de l'élection régionale qui se
tenait parallèlement sont les suivants
le rpr locale le rpcr obtient 35 sièges
sur les 48 à pourvoir dans le futur
congrès de l'assemblée législative
locale
le front national obtient 8 sièges de
liste divers droite 3 sièges et enfin
une liste constituée par des
indépendantistes dissidents qui n'avait
pas répondu aux ordres de boycott du
vote disposera lui de deux sièges
la participation a été de 56 37% lors du
référendum en septembre dernier
également boycotté il faut le signaler
par les indépendantistes la
participation avait été de 59,1 pour ce
la journée de vote en nouvelle calédonie
a été marquée par la mort d'un quatrième
gendarme grièvement blessé lors de la
prise d'otages de ses 26 collègues il y
a trois jours 26 gendarmes qui reste
toujours retenus en otages par des
indépendantistes journée marquée
également par des incidents en brousse
dix gendarmes ont été blessés dont un
assez sérieusement
alors que le scrutin s'est déroulé
normalement dans la capitale du
territoire
nouméa où résident la majorité de la
population
dominique tierces dominique merlet
bulletin bleu pour les élections
présidentielles orange pour les
régionales
les habitants de nouvelle calédonie ont
voté deux fois participation massive à
nouméa comme dans la grande majorité des
communes du sud et de l'ouest de l'île
abstention importante dans l'est et dans
les loyautés 139 bureaux de vote sur
l'ensemble du territoire
une trentaine d'entre eux n'ont pu
fonctionner des élections encadrés par
de nombreuses patrouilles des forces de
l'ordre aujourd'hui encore huit
gendarmes ont été blessés par des coups
de feu des jets de pierres ou des engins
incendiaires
branchages tronc d'arbre cloud bris de
verre les indépendantistes ont empêché
toute circulation aujourd'hui en
direction de canal à un village de la
côte est
il répondait au mot d'ordre du fln
caisse un mot d'ordre qui appelait selon
les termes employés par le bureau
politique à une mobilisation musclée de
fait on voyait de nombreuses armes sur
les barrages installés par les jeunes
indépendantistes des tribus c'est
d'ailleurs ici que quelques heures après
notre passage six gendarmes ont été
blessés alors qu'ils tentaient de
dégager la voie
tension extrême aussi sur l'île de maré
furent celles de lifou à saint louis
dans la banlieue de nouméa
il avançait avec beaucoup de précaution
à la recherche de tireurs isolés
c'est donc une situation pour le moins
délicate que bernard pons trouvera à son
arrivée sur le territoire à ouvéa on est
toujours sans nouvelles les gendarmes
prise en otage depuis trois jours pour
les indépendantistes est l'un de ceux
qui a été grièvement blessé lors de
l'attaqué du cantonnement de fayaoué
vient de décéder
la nuit dernière sur l'île d'ouvéa en
nouvelle-calédonie les 23 personnes qui
étaient détenus en otages ont elles
aussi y était libéré contexte différent
vous le savez car sur place en nouvelle
calédonie les forces de l'ordre ont
lancé un assaut contre les preneurs
d'otages le bilan est très lourd
17 morts quinze militants
indépendantistes et deux militaires
l'opération a débuté à 6h15 heure locale
mais les 300 représentants des forces de
l'ordre qui ont donné l'assaut à la
grotte réputée imprenable non délivrer
les otages qu après 8 heures d'efforts
au cours d'une conférence de presse
donnée au commissariat à nouméa
bernard pons a détaillé le déroulement
des événements indiquant que de revolver
de gros calibre et des clés de menottes
avaient été fournies aux captifs leur
permettant ainsi de participer à la
fusillade depuis l'intérieur de la
grotte
l'effet de surprise n'a pas joué tout à
fait les ravisseurs au nombre d'une
trentaine était parfaitement organisé
je savais que ce serait une opération
difficile parce que je crois que c'est
une prise d'otage qui fait date ce la
preuve de la généralement on se trouve
face à deux ou trois ravisseurs armés
d'un mauvais pistolet là on avait une
véritable bande armée
donc je savais que c'était une opération
difficile et je voulais prendre toutes
les précautions prendre mon temps pour
la préparer et si l'on avait pu obtenir
que les ravisseurs rendent danse otages
sans attaquer le site
j'aurais été ravi malheureusement ça n'a
pas été possible
en dépit de ces événements est du lourd
bilan de l'opération le calme règne
maintenant en nouvelle calédonie mais le
fln ks dénonce l'intervention militaire
higuain est où est né et ses amis parle
de gâchis de morts inutiles qui seront
vengés
le bilan de l'opération d'ouvéa qui a
fait je vous le rappelle dix sept morts
six blessés 15 arrestations suscite
quelques réserves dans la classe
politique
je vous propose d'écouter trois
réactions collecter tout à l'heure par
bernard pradines haut il est clair
maintenant que monsieur chirac et les
siens pratiquer une politique de coups
de théâtre et essaye de peser sur les
émotions collectives des français en ce
qui concerne l'opération militaire en
nouvelle calédonie qui est concomitante
et qui intervient également trois jours
avant le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
elle a abouti à la libération des
gendarmes et du magistrat
c'est est un impératif absolu mais elle
se termine par 17 morts j'approuve le
gouvernement d'avoir pris cette méthode
est d'avoir fait refait obtenir force à
la loi
je crois que il y a des moments où
gouvernement doit faire face ces doit
faire front et faire respecter
l'autorité de la loi et de l'état le
gouvernement français s'est livré ce
matin un acte purement coloniale c'est
la politique de la canonnière et ce qui
s'est passé ce matin ne grandit pas le
lit majeur 23 gendarmes ont été libérés
mais au prix de la mort de quinze canal
on ne peut pas considérer cela comme un
succès et cela fait surtout la
démonstration que la vida mélanésiens
n'a décidément pas le même prix que
celle d'un blanc en nouvelle calédonie
calme sous tension ainsi peut-on on
vient de le voir s'exprimer à propos de
la nouvelle calédonie à la veille du
vote de demain
le ministre des territoires et
départements d'outre-mer monsieur
bernard pons à quitter le territoire et
apparemment les indépendantistes du fln
ks n'ont pas l'intention de troubles et
de troubler par dont la journée du
scrutin tout de même les forces de
l'ordre sont en état d' alerte maximum
françois cornet mission spéciale
aujourd'hui en nouvelle calédonie pour
les pelotons de gendarmerie mobile
lesportes jusqu'aux bureaux de vote dans
les points les plus chauds notamment
ceux de la côte est de la grande terre
des représentants de l'état comme ce
fonctionnaire qui embarque ici dans un
berger un véhicules blindés à roues de
la gendarmerie chargés de surveiller le
scrutin de transmettre à nouméa par
radio les taux de participation à
différentes heures de la journée et les
résultats du vote
ces représentants de l'état seront
présents dans toutes les mairies leur
transport par engin blindé illustre bien
le climat de tension qui règne ici
après laffaire d'ouvéa et à la veille de
ce deuxième tour être transportés comme
ça avec des engins blindés
ça fait un drôle d'effet ça fait
peut-être dans les faits mais fait pour
la sécurité au niveau bien
vigilance et précaution deux consignes
données aux forces de l'ordre pour
assurer sur la grande terre et sur les
îles le déroulement dans la légalité de
l'élection présidentielle à l'heure où
bernard 11 qui est aujourd'hui le
territoire pour paris laissant tôt au
commissaire délégué du gouvernement tous
les pouvoirs en nouvelle calédonie les
escadrons de gendarmerie eux faisait
mouvement vers les bureaux de vote pour
assurer demain leur protection
deux mille sept cents gendarmes ont été
mobilisés pour cette mission
l'ensemble des unités de la gendarmerie
et des autres armées ont été mises en
état d' alerte en nouvelle calédonie à
nouméa les indépendantistes du fln ks
n'accepte pas la version officielle de
l'assaut donné par les forces de l'ordre
pour libérer les 23 gendarmes otages la
semaine dernière il affirme que le chef
du commando indépendantiste et 2 des
siens ont voulu se rendre et qu'ils ont
été abattus faut absolument faux répond
le général vidal qui commandait l'assaut
dans l'île d'ouvéa sur les lieux même de
la faire se sont déroulées aujourd'hui
les obsèques des 19 indépendantistes
tués lors de l'attaqué de la grotte où
ils séquestraient les gendarmes otages
et parallèlement sur cette terre encore
remarqué de violences avait lieu le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle françois corner au delà
des événements ces cercueils alignés
dans une fosse commune creusée dans le
corail au bord du pacifique marqueront
durant longtemps la conscience des
habitants des îles et de toute la
nouvelle calédonie qui n'oubliera jamais
ouvéa le nom d'un atoll paradisiaque
avant ce matin là aujourd'hui la
communauté kanak est venu voter dans la
petite mairie jouxtant la gendarmerie le
meurtre des gendarmes
la prise d'otages la socopa la grotte
les 19 morts de l'île et ceux des forces
de l'ordre sont dans toutes les
consciences mais de devoir pour la
france sur cette île du bout de monde à
20000 km de la métropole a été accompli
par la quasi totalité des habitants à
100% cadac
à paris la polémique continue autour de
l'aso d'ouvéa précisément le ministre de
la défense monsieur jean pierre
chevènement affirmé aujourd'hui qu'il
était un peu trop facile de faire porter
le chapeau aux militaires qui ont donné
l'assaut écoutez le il m'apparaît bon à
part que toutes les possibilités de
médiation n'ont pas été utilisés je
parle de médiation avec les ravisseurs
par monsieur penche et que la décision
d'intervenir comporter de très gros
risque pour la vie des 23 gendarmes
retenus en otage
quant à l'exécution de l'opération de
libération
trois jours avant le deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle elle était
extrêmement périlleuse il me paraît pour
ma part un peu trop facile de faire
porter le chapeau aux militaires qui ont
eu deux tués dans l'assaut
je souhaite que dans l'intérêt de la
france et de la démocratie
les préjugés n'en porte pas des
conclusions prématurées et injuste
sur la base de témoignages qui sont
forcément très fragile
dans une affaire où par ailleurs la
justice est saisie et doit faire son
travail
imprévisible jacques lafleur le pilier
du rpr local porte-drapeau de la lutte
anti indépendantistes
depuis plusieurs mois ils demandaient
avec force la dissolution du fln caisse
aujourd'hui il accepte de rencontrer ses
adversaires jean marie tjibaou voire de
négocier avec lui à certaines conditions
quand ils meurent à retrouver cette
liberté d'appartenir à un parti qui
donne son opinion mais qui ne veut rien
imposer par la violence tous les espoirs
sont permis en quelques semaines deux
événements ont sans doute pesé dans la
réflexion du député la fleur mais aussi
de tous les esprits en nouvelle
calédonie deux événements qui ont agit
en quelque sorte comme des électrochocs
la tragique affaire d'ouvéa la
réélection de françois mitterrand à la
présidence de la république
lorsque la mission nommée par le premier
ministre arrive à nouméa c'est pour
entendre écouter renoué comme on l'a dit
souvent les fils du dialogue
un objectif aujourd'hui partiellement
accomplie de la côte est à la côte ouest
partis politiques syndicats hommes
d'église partenaires économiques
tous ont été reçus chacun des six
envoyés spéciaux enregistré des dizaines
de témoignages pour le préfet christian
blanc il doit à présent remettre un
rapport à michel rocard
il ne s'agit pas pour lui d'élaborer un
nouveau statut
cela c'est la tâche du gouvernement
pourtant jacques lafleur lui y pense à
ce futur statut dans une interview
accordée au figaro
il déclare ne pas être favorable à une
partition du territoire
mais dit il un mauvais accord vaut mieux
qu'une bonne guerre civile ce n'est pas
sans surprise que ses propos ont été
enregistrés à nouméa surprise au sein du
propre parti de jacques lafleur
surprise aussi des indépendantistes
je pense que le temps est intéressant il
est sûr que nous avons dans cette
période et surtout depuis 86 maintenant
qu'est ce qu'il y a dans le panier des
sacrifices et concessions je ne sais pas
non de toute façon on attend aussi pour
voir la période semble donc propice à
une rencontre des différents partenaires
concernés par l'avenir de la nouvelle
calédonie est pour l'instant sur cet
avenir
le gouvernement affirme avoir aucune
idée préconçue
madame monsieur bonjour on savait qu'il
était important pour le premier ministre
monsieur michel rocard de trouver très
vite un début de solution aux problèmes
de la nouvelle calédonie il l'avait dit
et bien ce matin à l'aube 4 heures du
matin exactement à l'hôtel matignon
un accord a été signé entre le
gouvernement et toutes les parties
intéressées indépendantistes et anti
indépendantistes aux termes de cet
accord l'état va administrer directement
le territoire pour une durée d'un an
l'ensemble du peuple français va être
consultés par référendum sur les
nouvelles institutions à mettre en place
en nouvelle calédonie enfin un scrutin
d'autodétermination sera organisée sur
le territoire et cela dans un délai de
dix ans voilà pour les grandes lignes de
l'accord sur lequel nous allons revenir
mais tout de suite la chronologie des
événements de ce matin véronique sainte
lille philippe baron et les moyens à
chef d'antenne jean marie tjibaou et
jacques lafleur côte à côte
michel rocard leur faisant face c'était
à matignon en fin de matinée la corse où
la nouvelle calédonie venait d'être
signé et si tous les problèmes ne sont
pas résolus loin de là pour tous un
grand parent venait d'être franchie
depuis quinze jours
au terme de longues heures de
négociations les délégations nouvelle
calédonie conduite par monsieur lafleur
et tibaous ont ensemble donné leur
accord à ce que l'état reprenne
pour les 12 prochains mois l'autorité
administrative sur le territoire de
manière à garantir la partialité de
l'action publique la sécurité la
protection de tous doivent être assurés
des actions de développement économique
et social et de formation seront mises
en oeuvre notamment pour les régions
défavorisées à l'automne je proposerai
monsieur le président de la république
qui a suivi avec une extrême attention
l'ensemble de ces conversations que le
peuple français soit consulté par
référendum sur ces institutions
nouvelles afin qu'il apporte lui le
peuple français
sa garantie la plus haute le plus fiable
la plus durable dans dix ans dans dix
ans par un nouveau scrutin
d'autodétermination
c'est à nos compatriotes de nouvelle
calédonie eux-mêmes qu'il appartiendra
de choisir les voies et moyens de leur
veste et le sentiment après quinze jours
de négociation de travail que nous avons
réussi à comprendre tous autant que nous
sommes que nous devions savoir donner
savoir pardonner et c'est ce que nous
sommes parvenus à faire je le crois pour
l'avenir
choisir entre pouvoir travailler ensuite
l'été et s'entretuer je pense que les
délégations étaient conscientes
c'était même émouvant parfois et je
pense que nathalie denis
même si pour les militants c'est un peu
du les têtes dans l'immédiat parce que
l'avenir sera reconnaître que ces
accords ont constitué un pas important
les bases de l'accord sont établis reste
maintenant aux responsables en préciser
le contenu
eo population calédonienne à le vivre
mesdames messieurs bonsoir le fait du
jour est bien entendu politique
jean-marie tjibaou jacques lafleur et
michel rocard ont signé hier soir à
paris un accord sur l'avenir du
territoire
c'est donc l'aboutissement d'un
processus de discussions engagées à
nouméa d'abord puis directement à
l'hôtel matignon sous la responsabilité
des plus hautes autorités de l'état
cet accord politique au delà de son
aspect symbolique prévoit plusieurs
volets et c'est le premier ministre
lui-même qui lors d'une conférence de
presse à paris a rendu public les
dispositions de cet accord
benoît saudeau
depuis quinze jours au terme de longues
heures de négociations les délégations
nouvelle calédonie fondée par messieurs
l'asthme avec tibaous ont ensemble donné
leur accord à ce que vesta reprennent
pour les 12 prochains mois
l'autorité administrative sur le
territoire de manière à garantir la
partie héritée de l'action publique à
l'automne
je proposerai à monsieur le président de
la république j'ai suivi avec une
extrême attention lancement de ces
conversations que le peuple français
soit consulté par référendum
si c'est là dessus que ces institutions
nouvelles afin qu'il apporte lui le
peuple français
sa garantie la plus haute la plus fiable
la plus durable dans dix ans dans dix
ans
par un nouveau scrutin
d'autodétermination c'est à nos
compatriotes de nouvelle-calédonie peut
même qu'il appartiendra de choisir les
choisit moyens de leur dise le reste de
l'actualité maintenant premier discours
de michel rocard en nouvelle calédonie
le premier ministre a appelé les
français à relever le défi de la
décolonisation
moins d'une semaine après la signature
définitive de l'accord sur l'avenir du
territoire
michel rocard a tenu à se rendre
lui-même sur place compte rendu tout de
suite rachida à petit conseil des
ministres à 10000 mètres d'altitude
envole vers nouméa michel rocard pierre
bérégovoy
pierre joxe et louis le pensec travail
sur dossier avant d'être confronté à la
réalité calédoniennes en découvrant la
nouvelle calédonie profonde
michel rocard a certes fait connaissance
avec des coutumes mais aussi avec des
problèmes concrets et quotidien
aujourd'hui michel rocard a beaucoup
parlé d'éducation d'agriculture ou
encore de transport sur l'île de lifou
le premier ministre s'est déplacé lui
même en automne
retour ensuite vers les problèmes plus
politique à l'hôtel de ville de nouméa
avec une surprise ces habitants européen
de la capitale calédonienne
applaudissent un certain jean marie
tjibaou arrivée aux côtés de jacques
lafleur un exploit accompli par jean
lèques le maire de nouméa chaudement
félicité par michel rocard qui a sauté
sur l'occasion pour s'adresser sans
équivoque aux leaders du rpcr et du rhdp
n 15 je l'aï dit dès le premier jour le
les personnes
mon souhait est qu'en 1998 les
populations nouvelle calédonie
choisissent de rester dans l'ensemble
français mais en même temps je ferai
tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir
mon devoir pour que le droit
constitutionnel tel qu'écrit dans notre
constitution à l'autodétermination
s'exerce librement loyalement
équitablement ce qui peut conduire à la
dépendance et dans la fidélité des
confiance et non dans la rue ben du
dernières scènes fortes de cette journée
du premier ministre en nouvelle
calédonie on entend de la marseillaise
jean marie tjibaou reste impassible
alors que michel rocard chantent l'hymne
national jamais le premier ministre
n'avait exprimé aussi clairement qu'ils
ne s'opposeraient pas à l'indépendance
le cas échéant
et cela même si son coeur est contre
bonsoir il s'agit exclusivement de
rétablir la paix en nouvelle calédonie
c'est ainsi que tout à l'heure à la
télévision
monsieur michel rocard a défini l'objet
du référendum du 6 novembre prochain ce
matin le conseil des ministres en a
confirmé la date et on connaît désormais
la formulation de la question qui sera
posée aux français tout de suite
écoutons un extrait de la déclaration de
michel rocard
oui le 6 novembre prochain votre voix
sera la voix de la france
les représentants de la nouvelle
calédonie l'on souhaitait pour disposer
de la durée de la stabilité nécessaire
votre vote pour l'avenir de la
nouvelle-calédonie sera à leur égard un
geste de fraternité c'est aussi
l'intérêt de la france sur ses rives
lointaines du pacifique sud où se jouent
déjà les grands défis du prochain
millénaire
si grâce à votre soutien nous
réussissons nous la france réussit son
dans cette entreprise
quel que soit le destin que nos
compatriotes de nouvelle calédonie se
choisiront dans dix ans la france
restera présente et respecté dans cette
partie du monde
oui vraiment devant appareils en jeu
celui de la paix civile
celui de la fraternité celui du
rayonnement de la france des droits de
l'homme comment peut-on résister vous le
redit avec force
il s'agit dans cette consultation de la
nouvelle calédonie de la paix sur le
territoire de son avenir réconcilier et
de rien d'autre
il ne s'agit pas de voter soit pour
l'indépendance de la nouvelle calédonie
soit pour son maintien dans la
république française
ce choix là ce sont nos compatriotes de
nouvelle calédonie qui auront à le faire
dans 10 ans à travers d'un scrutin
d'autodétermination selon la procédure
prévue par notre constitution et accepté
par la charte des nations unies
alors l'assassinât de jean marie tjibaou
numéro un du fln caisse alors c'était
l'homme des accords de matignon avec
michel rocard c'est précisément ces
images que nous allons revoir avec un
commentaire de roland sicard et après
nous parlerons de jean marie tjibaou
nous fera un portrait de lui et les
commentaires de gilles permet d'abord
les accords de matignon c'était il ya
quelques temps
juin 1980 huit accords de matignon jean
marie tjibaou et jacques lafleur les
deux ennemis réductible autour d'une
table l' amorce d'un processus qui
devait déboucher vers la paix c'était le
début du dialogue
depuis quinze jours au terme de longues
heures de négociations les délégations
nouvelle calédonie conduite par monsieur
lafleur et tibaous ont ensemble donné
leur accord à ce que l'état reprenne
pour les 12 prochains mois
l'autorité administrative sur le
territoire de manière à garantir la
partialité de l'action publique la
sécurité la protection de tous doivent
être assurés des actions de
développement économique et social et de
formation seront mises en oeuvre
notamment pour les régions défavorisées
à l'automne
je proposerai monsieur le président de
la république qui a suivi avec une
extrême attention
l'ensemble de ces conversations que le
peuple français soit consulté par
référendum sur ces institutions
nouvelles afin qu'il apporte lui le
peuple français
sa garantie la plus haute le plus fiable
la plus durable dans dix ans dans dix
ans par un nouveau scrutin
d'autodétermination
c'est à nos compatriotes de nouvelle
calédonie eux-mêmes qu'il appartiendra
de choisir les voies et moyens de leur
destin bien le sentiment après quinze
jours de négociation de travail que nous
avons réussi à comprendre tous autant
que nous sommes que nous devions savoir
donner savoir pardonner
et c'est ce que nous sommes parvenus à
faire je le crois pour l'avenir choisir
entre pouvoir travailler on sait tout
l'été et s'entretuer je pense que les
délégations étaient conscientes
c'était même émouvant parfois et je
pense que nathalie denis
même si pour les militants c'est un peu
du jeu tête dans l'immédiat parce que
l'avenir seul à reconnaître que ces
accords ont constitué un pas important
des militants qu'il fallait encore
convaincre et qui sont peut-être à
l'origine de l'assassinât de jean marie
tjibaou
selon les premières informations des
militants du fût l'une des composantes
d'extrême gauche du fln gaz serait à
l'origine de l'attentât
jean marie tjibaou avait 53 ans
élections provinciales demain en
nouvelle calédonie 91000 calédonie et
calédoniens sont appelés à élire leurs
représentants aux provinces nord sud est
il vain liste 430 candidats au total
pour un test grandeur nature
après les accords de matignon daniel
sportello la consultation du 11 juin en
nouvelle calédonie doit concrétiser une
poignée de main historique celle qui mit
face à face le 26 juin 88 à matignon le
leader indépendantiste jean-marie
tjibaou est le chef de file des
anti-indépendantistes jacques lafleur
pour le scrutin de demain
fl heynckes et rpcr sont à nouveau face
à face
un mois après l'assassinât de jean marie
tjibaou l'enjeu la majorité au congrès
du territoire qui devrait revenir aux
anti indépendantistes est un enjeu
considérable
les élus des trois provinces sud nord et
îles prévues par les accords matignon
auront en effet une autonomie politique
et économique totale dès le 14 juillet
une date qui marque la fin de
l'administration directe que l'état
exerce depuis un an
selon les prévisions établies les
indépendantistes devrait contrôler les
provinces nord et îles minoritaire en
sièges et le rpr la province sud
autour de nouméa seule réelle
incertitude l'attitude de la branche
minoritaire du fln cas est ce le fut lui
qui s'opposent aux accords de matignon
et appelle à un boycott actif des
élections le fut le cas menacé de
s'attaquer à des objectifs économiques
et matériels pour faire échec au plan
rocard autre incertitude
jacques lafleur contesté par ceux qui
lui reprochent sa politique de la main
tendue aux indépendantistes
gardera-t-il le contrôle des loyalistes
au congrès s'il est désavoué
qu'en sera-t-il alors des accords de
matignon philippe legorjus bonsoir vous
écoutiez attentivement ce soir tous nos
reportages que pensez vous de ce climat
de violence je rappelle que vous êtes
l'ancien commandant du gign écoutez ce
climat de violence me rappelle et
malheureusement des actes de violence
que j'ai eu à connaître lorsque j'étais
patron du gign actes de violence plus
redoutable encore peut-être puisque
c'étaient des actes qui généralement
emporté la mort de certaines personnes
mais ce que je vois aujourd'hui c'est
aussi une violence contre l'esprit
et lorsque l'on en est à ce stade on
n'est pas loin de ce qu'on a pu
connaître une aussi alors philippe
legorjus on vous a invité pour un livre
que vous venez d'écrire la morale et
l'action publié par les éditions fixot
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure vous étiez
le commandant du gène à 34 ans et vous
avez été l'un des acteurs du drame
d'ouvea lors votre livre se lit comme un
roman mais c'est pas un roman c'est un
récit la prise d'otages oui je crois pas
que ce soit uniquement un récit prise de
ta je crois que j'ai voulu au delà des
faits essayer de voir comment on pouvait
à partir de règles de règles morales que
l'on peut s'imposer personnellement ou
que l'on respecte dans la vie en société
on pouvait confronter ces règles à des
phénomènes de violence comme ceux dont
on vient de parler et à trouver des
moyens à la fois techniques et moraux de
résoudre ces problèmes de violence alors
bien sûr la sphère d'ouvéa philippe
legorjus où vous avez été vous étiez
bien sûr le commandant du gign
vous avez aussi joué un rôle très
politique pendant ces événements n'ont à
mon niveau je ne considère pas que c'est
un rôle politique
lorsque vous avez à traiter une affaire
de prise d'otages vous essayez de la
traiter dans sa globalité afin d'obtenir
le meilleur résultat possible
effectivement vous prenez en compte les
paramètres politiques
et si vous vous apercevez à un moment ou
un autre du traitement de la crise qu'il
faut aussi jouer d'une façon ou d'une
autre sur le politique bien vous le
faites je crois qu'il faut pas avoir de
regrets par rapport à ça c'est parce que
je considère de dire que c'est pas une
attitude marginal ou désobéissante par
rapport à des règles établies
c'est la volonté de prendre tous les
moyens pour arriver à une solution de
libération d'otages
mais vous étiez très perturbé par la
coïncidence entre ce drame d'ouvea il ya
une chance présidentielle
mais l'élection présidentielle était je
vais dire presque la cause de cette
prise d'otages
c'est parce qu'ils avaient élection
présidentielle très certainement que les
mélanésiens ont décidé d'attaquer la
brigade de fayaoué et d'assassiner
quatre gendarmes aussi toi mais c'est
tout de même vous qui avait tenu
l'elysée au courant j'ai tenu au courant
et nous dit dans livre tout à fait j'ai
tenu au courant un homme à l'elysée
c'est ce que je dis dans le livre cet
homme s'appelle christian prouteau
il est le fondateur du gign et
contrairement à ce qu'on a pensé
j'ai toujours cru que le gouvernement de
l'époque informées normalement par les
voies normales l'elysée ce que je
voulais c'est que le président à travers
christian couteau et est vraiment une
appréciation j'ai à dire presque
psychologique et intimiste de la façon
dont vous pouvez résoudre le problème
vous parlez souvent de violences dans
votre livre dans votre vie mais ce n'est
pas le sentiment que la politique est
quelque fois encore plus violentes qu'on
imagine
et quel jeu sert quelquefois non enfin
j'ai pas vraiment cette impression moss
est aujourd'hui à travers l'action qui
était la mienne que me chef du gign
j'ai établi une réflexion et cette
réflexion c'est qu'il faut aider au
contraire le politiques à résoudre
techniquement et en dehors de toute
contingence je sais pas si le mot est
bien choisi essayer de bien résoudre de
bien
visionnez la la finalité de respect de
la vie et de la mort par rapport aux
acteurs des unités d'intervention comme
celle que je demande c'est curieux vous
semblez à la fois lucide et un petit peu
candide est ce que vraiment la morale à
sa place dans l'action est ce que
vraiment la morale à sa place dans
l'action politique
je crois que la morale à sa place dans
la vie tout court quelle que soit la
forme cette vie merci philippe legorjus
la nouvelle calédonie ou l'histoire
d'une fracture il y a dix ans michel
rocard qui était alors premier ministre
réussissait à ramener le calme sur le
territoire en faisant signer les accords
de matignon
les amarres goût revient sur cette
période tourmentée poignée de main
historique entre jean marie tjibaou et
jacques lafleur
nous sommes le 26 juin 1988 le fln
caisse et le rpcr viennent de signer
sous l'égide de michel rocard alors
premier ministre
les accords de matignon il fixe le
statut du territoire pour les dix ans à
venir jusqu'à l'organisation d'un
référendum local d'autodétermination en
1998 pour la nouvelle calédonie c'est la
fin d'un climat de violence qui avait
culminé un mois auparavant à ouvéa
l'assaut de l'armée contre les preneurs
d'otages indépendantiste réfugiés dans
cette grotte s'était soldée par plus
d'une vingtaine de morts que si on se
parlait pour arriver à des conclusions
il faudrait qu'elle sait la solennité
pas d'accord gouvernement la france mais
du peuple français
c'est donc par référendum que son
ratifier les accords de matignon
le 6 novembre 1988 jean marie tjibaou et
le numéro deux du fln ksv win et win et
paieront de leur vie le nouveau statut
de l'île ils sont assassinés en 89 par
un indépendantiste extrémistes fln
caresser rpcr chercheront un compromis
entre indépendance et autonomie au sein
de la république jusqu en 96 et c'est
seulement le 1er février dernier après
un accord portant sur des gisements
miniers que les négociations ont pu
reprendre d'ici 15 à 20 ans les
habitants de la nouvelle calédonie
seront appelés par référendum à dire oui
ou non à l'indépendance c'est la
principale mesure qui découle de
l'accord signé hier entre l'état et les
partis de l'île des antilles d'olivier
caroff
la nouvelle calédonie est un indépendant
les négociateurs n'en reparlerons pas
avant au moins 15 ans mais en attendant
l'accord conclu hier propose une
souveraineté partagée à mi chemin entre
l'autonomie proposée par les caldoches
et l'indépendance réclamé par les kanaks
un texte que lionel jospin viendra
signer dans quelques jours et sur lequel
la population sera bientôt consulter ont
signé un accord pour la nouvelle
calédonie sa population au sol dans la
suite de ce que les signataires des
accords de matignon avait rappelé au
moment où ils ont signé les accords de
ça va très vite
le pari sur notre jeu il y a dix ans et
un référendum sur l'indépendance qui
était prévu pour cette année
en échange de leur patience les
héritiers de jean marie tjibaou ont
obtenu une nouvelle organisation du
pouvoir politique
lille sera dirigé par un gouvernement
collégial l'identité kanak sera reconnue
et affirmé
l'état n'aura plus à terme qu'à assurer
l'ordre public la justice et la défense
des deux cent mille habitants du caillou
l'état va en plusieurs étapes
progressivement donné à la calédonie
la plupart des compétences et une
conservera à la fin du processus que ce
qu'on appelle les compétences
régaliennes un engagement pris à une
date hautement symbolique
dix ans jour pour jour après le massacre
de la grotte d'ouvéa 19 indépendantistes
et deux militaires avaient trouvé la
mort lors d'une prise d'otages on se
souvient encore des affrontements
sanglants de la tragédie d'ouvéa qui
avaient opposé des gendarmes à un groupe
d'indépendantistes kanaks
vint ensuite les accords de matignon
sous la présidence de michel rocard
depuis la répartition des richesses
nouvelle calédonie a été mieux assurée
entre kanaks et caldoches venus de
métropole ce progrès étaient sans aucun
doute à l'origine de l'accord qui sera
signé demain et qui prévoit pour une
quinzaine d'années encore la
souveraineté française benoît duquesne
dominique merlet mêmes pays qui ont les
mêmes bases à dubaï
nous sommes à vos dans le nord du
territoire et ceux qui se nouent ici par
cet échange de paroles et de gestes
coutumier vaut bien plus que tous les
contrats les responsables des clans et
des chefferies sont là pour concrétiser
une entente est confiée solennellement
l'exploitation de leurs montagnes à une
société minière la smsp société kanak
issu des accords de matignon qui s'allie
aux grands groupes canadiens
falconbridge nous sommes avec vous j'ai
pour mon dire attention le nickel c'est
la grande affaire de la calédonie le
préalable qui a failli faire retarder
les accords de nouméa source de pouvoir
et de richesse il a longtemps été la
possession exclusive des blancs avant
d'être confiés pour partie à la smsp et
à son directeur rappelle jo c'est aussi
le symbole de ce rééquilibrage tant
recherchée entre le nord et le sud entre
les kanaks et les blancs
c'est pas une revanche c'est un juste
retour de l'histoire parce que les
canards ont été déplacées leurs droits
étaient bafoués pendant un siècle
des jaunes une replacer ossements de
car les kanak ont su tirer profit de ce
cadeau qui leur avait été fait avec le
nickel ils ont multiplié les embauches
très investi dans le territoire
favoriser la création d'entreprises sous
traitantes comme celle ci pascal naouna
est aujourd'hui à la tête d'une
trentaine de salariés et de huit camions
il y a dix ans était l'un des durs des
indépendantistes de ceux qui organisent
les barrages et attaquent les forces de
l'ordre où les caldoches dans les autres
cas le buzz qui sont qui était dans les
ministres de nespouls y en ait pas
maintenant ils ont des entreprises que
çà et là bas maintenant on travaille on
travaille ensemble qu'ils ont besoin
d'une pelle velours la mentalité elle
évolue doucement et entregent de brochon
on arrive à s'entendre et de fête
l'ambiance a changé non pas que les
caldoches soit devenu indépendantiste
loin s'en faut mais un certain respect
mutuel s'est installé jusque chez les
plus intransigeants d'entre ces fameux
caldoches de la brousse
et j'ai lu dans un journal qui parlait
de destin commun ça va être un destin
quand même pas pour rien d'autre on
bougera pas et on croit pas lecteur donc
on a tout intérêt à s'entendre
et donc ces destins communs vous voyez
comment vous le voyez toujours dans la
france tant que la française de rester
moi je vois pas pourquoi séparer d'une
bonnement d'isolement d'une bâche médias
et travailler avec les caennais vous et
soyez prêt à bien sûr jamais tout à fait
il va falloir qu'ils apprennent à
travailler la terre non on a appris à
travailler avec nos parents qu'ils
apprennent à la mettre en valeur
il est d'avoir des hectares et des
hectares qui a réfléchi car france de
bien c'est que le plus dur reste à faire
et qu'en dehors du nickel et de saman
redistribuées en dehors de la province
nord et de ses mille deux cents
fonctionnaires en dehors des
infrastructures cofinancé par l'état les
projets et les réalisations kanak sont
rares
léopold ii j'aurais dû et le sait mieux
que personne lui qui préside la province
nord passé le temps des aides et des
subventions
la révolution kanak reste encore à
accomplir on peut pas continuer demain
dans une même nation pour tout le monde
à dire ben vous les gamins nous les
canards nous on veut rester chez nous
avec le droit à pratiquer une ossature
particulier nos réserves
et puis vous les blancs
regardez le droit aux mains ok d'avoir
les mêmes mois beau tout le monde mais
vous payer les impôts mais pas ça c'est
assez à changer tout ça ça va prendre du
temps mais c'est ça la conscience
nationale et au sud
noumea prospère bien sûr la puissante
société le nickel a dû se résoudre à
perdre un peu de sa superbe au profit du
nord mais pour le reste les affaires
vont bon train en disant à coude et
fiscales de confiance retrouvée et de
dynamisme
la ville a explosé on a construit des
hôtels attirer les touristes
l'argent de l'état ici aussi s'est
déversé mais monsieur bonjour l'image de
la semaine c'est la poignée de mains de
trois hommes lionel jospin jacques
lafleur et roch wamytan trois mains
croisées qui scelle l'avenir de la
nouvelle-calédonie vers une plus large
autonomie
cette image restera le symbole d'une
évolution négocier de l'état français de
ses anciennes colonies
mais cet accord ne résout pas tout car
il n'a pas vous allez voir la même
signification pour tout le monde
nathalie nozière je suis persuadé que
dans 20 ans les calédoniens et les
calédoniennes choisiront de demeurer au
sein de la république l'indépendance ce
n'est pas pendant 20 ans elle commence à
se construire dès aujourd'hui en signant
l'accord de nouméa et féline ksc rpcr
espère conforter leur position
l'objectif à long terme reste le même
pour chacun l'indépendance ou le
maintien du lien avec la france un
clivage qui semble se retrouver dans la
population au marché de nouméa lieu où
se croisent des gens de toutes origines
on commente l'accord qui dans l'ensemble
semble plutôt bien accepté mais que se
passera-t-il dans 20 ans quel dommage
c'est kanak n'ont pas les mêmes réponses
la dépendance hongroise
cirelli petite cuvette la qualité et
donc indépendant mais il faut faire il
faut d'abord préparer les hommes c'est
comme si on est en larmes quand on voit
dans une guerre il faut d'abord que par
la maison pour aller sur le terrain ou
être des ongles des mains marginales des
chiens quatre générations
mais j'en ai une bannière d'un copié pas
les deux côtés avec des livres à cause
des bagnards
mais moi je pense que c'est pas une
mauvaise chose et puis toute façon c'est
nous qui allons décider
donc si on veut pas être indépendant 20
ans ne sera pas indépendant
si ça devient dépendant ça se passera
comme dans tous les autres pays et où
ils sont indépendants que maintenant ils
regrettent assez sûr pour le moment les
deux discours coexistent dans quinze ou
vingt ans un référendum y apportera une
réponse
en attendant le fln caisse et le rpcr
devront gérer ensemble leur pays avec
les nouvelles compétences qui leur
seront progressivement attribué le vrai
défi pour tous reste d'inventer un
avenir commun
[Musique]